a joe biden has tested positive for
covid again
he has absolutely no symptoms
is isolating out of an abundance of
caution but it is believed that this is
this sort of like rebound positivity
there are some claims it could be
related to the medication pax lavid that
pax levit helps you get over the virus
but then may be related to testing
positive again i'm not saying that
definitively that's one bit
of uh that's one claim that's being
evaluated but the belief is that this is
a
not uh
clinically significant testing positive
again now the former president donald
trump believes that this is actually the
wrong diagnosis that trump uh that biden
was diagnosed with covid but actually
the right diagnosis is dementia this is
a real post from a former president on
his uh social media platform truth
social truth essential and donald trump
said the following quote
joe biden's second bout of covid
sometimes referred to as the china virus
was sadly misdiagnosed by his doctors he
instead has capital d dementia but is
happily recovering well well at least
he's recovering from the dementia that's
good
joe is thinking of moving part time to
one of those beautiful wisconsin nursing
homes where almost 100 of the residents
miraculously and for the first time in
history had the strength and energy to
vote
even if those votes were cast illegally
get well soon joe
um
this is a former this is an outrageously
demented comment if you want to talk
about dementia that's a demented comment
but one of the fascinating things about
it is that unless you're following
the right wing
sort of grievance machine as david
roberts called it you don't even know
what trump's talking about david roberts
runs the newsletter volts about clean
energy great newsletter he posted about
trump's truth social post about biden's
covet dementia something pretty astute
he said the right-wing grievance machine
has become so insular and baroque that
it sounds like they're speaking another
language you have to immerse yourself in
the right-wing bubble for years to even
follow along and that's absolutely true
to understand what donald trump is even
referring to in that completely unhinged
post
you have to have been following
trump's lies and conspiracy theories for
several years there's like three inside
scam references you have to understand
one it's this whole thing of colin kova
the china virus
99 point whatever percent of the world
refers to it as covet or coronavirus
there's this group of people that follow
trump that call it the china virus it's
a republican trumpian thing you've got
to understand that number two biden
dementia that's another uh a thing that
donald trump has increasingly been
talking about and saying joe doesn't
even know where he is and all this sort
of stuff
and then three
the voter fraud in wisconsin nursing
homes the idea there's two versions of
that one version is the nursing homes
had 100 turnout and that doesn't make
sense it's also not true they didn't and
the second version is the nursing homes
voted 100 for joe biden and that doesn't
make sense that's also not true it's
another republican lie
another republican scam so understand
how
if you don't
follow the right wing scams
and you just say oh trump's not on
twitter
let's see what he posts on truth social
you would read that and have absolutely
no idea what on earth donald trump is
talking about they it's their own
language at this point they live in
their own world
and
that is not a normal thing for a former
president of the united states to post
the for the current president
has covered misdiagnosed it's actually
dementia that is insane but
in modern day 2022
it doesn't feel that surprising it's the
type of stuff trump's been saying for a
very long time crazy
crazy we'll take a quick break and be
right back
the only streaming service dedicated to
documentaries is curiosity stream our
long time sponsor on curiosity
curiositystream you will find the best
selection of documentaries better than
any other platform they've got the
newest and most critically acclaimed
titles i've been watching
curiositystream in my living room i
recently watched the six episode series
inside the mind of a con artist i'm
fascinated by scammers and cons and how
they get away with what they do
really great series that i can recommend
to you curiosity stream is always adding
new content they've got documentaries by
filmmakers we know and love but they
make it easy to find new independent
documentaries as well if you want to
absorb as much as you can
curiosity stream is for you if you want
to retain very little once you turn off
the tv you can also just relax with like
a nature documentary curiosity stream
has those too and with the special
discount for my audience you can get
curiosity stream for 15 bucks a year not
not a month a year that's under two
bucks a month go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below